so I want to spend just a few minutes
talking about the November 20 2011
because there's a very interesting new
study which found that if you break down
Donald from Sapru Ville rating in
counties where coronavirus is raging
versus in counties where it is not this
is a county level analysis counties that
are seeing the highest rates of
coronavirus explosion have seen a
dramatic drop in donald trump's approval
rating and the reason this is important
is that last week i did a segment
pointing out that you know when we think
about the biden versus trump debates
assuming that they happen biden pointing
out that trump is crass and makes fun of
people and is a bully and grab him by
the you-know-what and the racism and the
xenophobia and all that stuff it hasn't
worked so far and i can't imagine that
it's going to all of a sudden start
working for joe biden if that's the
approach he decides to take my instinct
was we've seen trump's approval come
down because of three major issues over
the last four months number one the
handling of coronavirus number two the
handling of the economy in the context
of the failed handling of coronavirus
and number three the insane reaction to
protests against police brutality which
included authoritarian anti speech
tendencies and threats to send in troops
with even more force to protests that
are against police brutality to begin
with that's where the focus should be
and particularly the failure of
leadership language aside if trump uses
coarse language but he crushes the virus
and does the right thing when it comes
to protests in the economy okay who's
gonna care about the course language and
that's basically my idea and indeed
donald trump has seen the fastest
declines in his approval rating in the
500 counties where there have been more
than twenty eight coronavirus deaths per
hundred thousand residents that's sort
of like the dividing line pew research
polling shows that seventeen percent of
the country which approved of trump in
march
now disapproved so it's starting with
just the slice that approved in March
seventeen percent of that now
disapproves and this is a in those
counties and this is a massive drop and
we're not even near the end of the
pandemic and it's always tragic when it
takes friends or family members getting
sick or dying to wake up and have a
realization it's like the anti-gay
Republican politician who changes their
tune
typically his tune but their tune when
someone they know comes out as gay great
they came to the right conclusion but
why did it take that you couldn't
empathize well it seems like that's at
least part of what's going on here and
there's a very reasonable debate over
how much is Trump's fault in terms of
the cases and deaths obviously people
were going to die you can't say of the
hundred and thirty two thousand deaths a
hundred and thirty two thousand are
Trump's fault but you can put numbers on
what was the cost of not developing a
testing program starting January 20th
the way South Korea did when we both got
our first cases on the same day you can
make estimates about what would a mask
recommendation have done early on what
would stay-at-home have done early on
hospitals could have maybe not been
underwhelm like you overwhelmed you can
put numbers to this and so you know
people who want to argue Trump doesn't
have 132 thousand deaths on his hands of
course he doesn't I don't know anyone
who's actually making that case what we
know is that there are specific policies
and specific actions including the
rollout of the testing program and many
other things that could have been done
differently which would have saved lives
and it's not could have been done
differently but nobody did them many
countries did South Korea is an example
there are many others remember that On
February 26 Donald Trump said we have 15
cases and 15 is soon going to zero that
was February 26th we now have almost
three million cases and a hundred and
thirty-two thousand deaths and cases are
exploding in a huge swath of this
country so that's the context and it is
again evidence that the pandemic and
Trump's reaction are dramatically
hurting his polling now to zoom out a
little bit bigger picture we continue to
get national polling where Trump is down
by double digits we also are seeing
Clear Politics polling averages in
Wisconsin Michigan Pennsylvania and
Florida where Biden is ahead by five or
more points that's insane Arizona which
has been a Republican stronghold for a
long time Biden ahead by an average of
three and a half and a half the really
crazy thing to think about is that if
Donald Trump had just taken medical
advice and gone the route of other
countries that chose chose science over
ignorance and action over politics if he
had controlled the coronavirus and
supported a shutdown supported an actual
real testing program starting in January
tracing initiatives etc etc he would
have an all but guaranteed re-election
in November I am increasingly confident
that that is that that that is how
important this is ultimately going to be
and it's also crazy to think that if
Trump and Pence had just caught the flu
or a bad intestinal bug on January 20th
and been m.i.a for a month and just let
medical doctors make decisions we would
also be far better off in other words
their presence was not only not positive
it was acutely negative in dealing with
coronavirus the data is in the polls and
so what do we all have to do now exactly
we don't believe any one of the polls we
imagine that our individual votes could
be the difference makers in our states
and every single one of us gets an
absentee ballot or goes and votes or
does whatever it is that we can do to
ensure that Donald Trump is removed in
November the polling looks good
ignore it pretend the polling looks
terrible pretend every state is 50/50
and that you could be the difference
maker